hey what's up guys my name is a general
local DEP so 50 of game programming so
yesterday we took a look at all the
different surprises that we created for
our randomly generated world and today
we're going to take a look at actually
you know making a map I guess so when I
start off by first of all you can see
that we've got way too many classes open
here I'm literally just going to right
click and hit up close all just to just
to clean up our our area here okay good
some because I like clean things as you
might do you might not anyway so let's
let's jump in so what I want here is the
level classes protector all we want to
focus on so right over here you'll see
that we've got our level class and right
now what happens is we started making
new level I guess with the string as
well possibly with string and then I
guess you know we're Andrew we get it
get the appropriate I'll this is sort of
like the the random method of getting
tiles it's not really how we want to get
tiles there are different there are many
different ways of actually getting tiles
which is why it's sort of um-hmm I guess
you'd say it's really up to you in a
sense but um the way that we're gonna
make maps in this game is we're
literally going to just draw them and
then we're gonna sort through pixels and
determine which color is which sprite
basically which tile so that'll make
sense when we actually implemented with
first of all I wanna run over here in
level so this is a navigator obviously
we've got level I'm so right click hit
new class and we're gonna make a new
level called spawn level now our spawn
level is just going to be like the main
place where because this is sort of like
an MMO right so it's gonna be like in
enrollment map got for example it's
gonna be that on that beginning place
I've got in the name of it because I'm
in played around with a magical
half a year but it's it's like the the
Nexus I think that's it right the Nexus
yeah anyway it's like that that area
where it's like the safe place like the
area and then from there you can sort of
enter different portals I guess to go to
different worlds and different levels
from there but the spawn level it's
going to be the spawn level so first of
all it extends level it's the most
important thing now obviously it needs
to it must define and explicit
constructor so the constructor that the
spawn level is going to actually define
will be the one that's string path
all right so let's just copy that and
paste it here right except instead of
blood level paths path understand type
and super pop right and that's it simple
is that
so um except obviously we have to change
level to spawn level that should should
be self-explanatory if you didn't know
that then I suggest you go back to some
kind of I don't know easier seriously I
don't know it's not to measure like your
guys understanding of Java because I
have no idea how experience through all
the job I feel that this series has
still attendant to people just taking
down card and on sending what it does I
guess it's because people ask me to
speed up and not explain everything but
I feel that if I do that I don't know my
R&R I don't know I don't know this
series hasn't really tended to what I
wanted to just enter which was literally
like a few lines of code per episode
teaching you guys like everything but um
I don't know it's sort of turned into
you guys probably just taking down card
and not really learning anything from it
which sucks but anyway I said the spawn
level what does this one level need to
do first of all it needs to you know at
lowest level from path so we got this
private void load level let's copy that
let's pass it here without that is
private is real problem let's make it
protected so that it
there yeah all right cool so protect
avoid load level um well what are we
gonna do here so this is the part where
we actually load the level from a file
now this is really important because um
this can be done many different ways the
way that I prefer to do it is I'm just
thinking okay well we can do it several
ways in fact we probably will do it
several ways and then we'll measure
performance so one of the ways to do it
and this is a bit on the slow side is
just simply make an array of tiles right
that's it
this is very precise though it's a bit
slower but hey it's precise that's what
matters
well actually that doesn't really matter
if you're if there's no point in to be
precise if it's running on one frame per
second but it won't be obviously not
another snotter's method so we'll make
tiles equal to new tile exactly one door
anything new yeah so load level string
path this is where we actually load the
level right so let's try and basically
load that image that I was talking about
so buffered image image equals image ir
doe read and then what's this cloth
called spawn level da class of care
resource and I love making you
subclasses cuz um if this actually fails
we all know that this happened in spawn
level which is really cool anyway so
we're loading it up part obviously
strength off which of course is this
thing
so let's import buffered image and let's
catch
and I'll probably just be an IO
exception that should I should be good
and we'll handle that later not now
sorry
whoops first thing we want to do is get
the whip and high of the image right and
we'll set the width and height to MW and
int age respectively so now that we got
the width and height all we really need
to do is kind of put it in right pixels
so let's make private int we'll call it
I guess
level pixels I really hate um I really
hate spelling level like that box spell
properly level pixels so image dot get
RGB so it will start a 0-0 with the
height will be WH RGB array will be
level pixels offset will be zeros
cancers will be W simple as that and
that said if we crash you know I don't
took the wheel but um we might actually
make an exception class in the future
under line there to exception level file
but not large level file all right
that's how I like to handle exceptions
there's another thing we get over to
wish you'd probably also on the start
resin in case there are any other issues
that are unseen okay awesome so now that
we've got a way to actually load level
pixels we need to deal with okay so what
does this do I'm sort of not explaining
this because we did do the same thing
for sprites but basically what this is
doing is it's loading is my audio
picking my audio might be begging I hate
when that happens because you can't I
fix that oh well I can make my like
friend quieter I think I'll do that now
actually I'm a bit quieter all right
there we go audio should be less picky
now but it will also be quieter sorry
guys and still hear me anyway so back to
this what I want to do here is so what
happens here is I'm loading an image
right from tequila path I'm calculated
that with no height of the image and
then I'm basically converting that image
into weight and to an array of pixels
and that array of pixels tells me which
color every pixel that images which is
really important because that's how
we're going to differentiate between
tiles so over here you guys can probably
tell the we need a method to convert
this into this all right that's what
we're gonna do now in level I'm gonna
make a protected void method called
Oh what shall we call it in fact I am
gonna call a generate level because even
though that's news by by our random
level you can see here it is generally
it is generally doing the same thing so
let's just do it so we're doing the
whoops swimming at the tiles of the top
way today and we'll take a look at how
that works performance base and then
we'll compare it with another way so
first off
let's just run that generate level so
protected for a generate level and yep
it is overwriting good I'll just pop it
on the theater because I like things to
be in chronological order I guess it
needs to both level first then generate
it even though it doesn't actually
matter chronologically I just like
reading it chronologically that's all
just to just just a personal preference
really so what does generate level need
to do generate level right essentially
needs to convert little pixels this
array of integers into this array of
tiles right little pixels into tiles so
how are we gonna do that
well first off we're gonna have to
basically show the level I guess but um
to actually convert pixels into tiles
integers and styles we obviously need to
figure out which pixels we want to be
which tiles and we will talk about that
next time so later guys hope you enjoy
the episode of game programming if you
did that like button is right there so
please hit the like button let's see if
we can get a hundred likes and we're
gonna if we can hit 100 likes I'll I'll
do something for you that's a totally
lame anyway later guys
you